All right,
welcome back to Computer Vision.
Today, we're going to finish our little
tour of the visual system of the I'm
sorry, the, of the human visual system.
The anatomy of the human system.
So when we last checked
in with our heroes we had
this little model going on here.
Remember, here's our nose over here.
Here's your eye, and it's got
the optic nerve going through the sa,
optic chiasm.
And it goes to this first area
called the lateral geniculate.
And then from the lateral geniculate
most of the stuff goes to the visual
cortex, although some goes to superior
colliculus, which we'll also talk about.
Last time also,
we discussed in some nauseating
detail what goes on in the retina.
So today is going to be sort of what
goes beyond from above the retina.